in this short tutorial I want to show
you how to identify the data set and
then find the data that you can download
and prepare the sample metadata for the
analysis okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to type in here the name of
the publication the date and the author
modeling precision medicine damn in 2013
so where you can see is I'm finding the
actual paper so I'm gonna click on here
this is under PubMed and then here on
the side I can find the Geo data sets or
this array so let's go over here will
give me a detailed view of the data sets
and I'm gonna be looking for expression
profiling by high-throughput sequencing
but this has other so in fact what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to take this one
expression profiling by how to put
sequencing we also know that it's 56
samples so let's click over here now
this is going to be the the data set you
can see the descriptions of the cell
lines that this is RNA seek data and
these are all of the samples let's go
over here bioproject that's where I want
to get to PR j and a 21 0 for 28 so I'm
going to click through over here okay
and now I can click on the 56 SRA
experiments and over here I will go
under send to the file and here I'll do
a run info create file so this is this
is what's in the file itself you can see
all the download path right here it will
provide me links to the SRR data for
each one of the samples and it will also
give me the other information that I
need for example that this is pair and
reads and the names of the samples and
what organism it should be mapped to the
files that we have are already uploaded
to the system
so now we are going to take the SVL file
that we have and we're going to create
our first RNA seek pipeline let's go
over here under RNA seek slash chip data
and we're going to make the selections
according to our data set so first of
all as you remember this is parent reads
and we will be using the model genome
the model genome being human genome so
we will use the latest assembly of the
human genome grch38 and we're going to
upload files and groups and because it
is already uploaded to the system we're
actually going to use this URL bulk
upload so let's take our svl we're going
to have cloud and lo versus normal like
samples here define groups check we
actually don't need groups because we're
not doing differential gene expression
and now let's create our pipeline so the
first option now pay attention every
time you click there's important
information right here that tells you a
lot of information that you can learn
from about the process that we are going
to be going through now the first thing
as we saw in the lecture is to prepare
the trim unnecessary amplification so we
want to first of all use trim Ematic to
clean technical sequences and these are
sequences that are stored in a databases
and again you can click on this link and
read about traumatic let's click on save
the next thing that we want to do is we
want to reduce the duplicate reads from
raw sequencing data how do we know that
these are technical duplicates or
replicates and not actual mapped reads
on the sequence well because they all
align perfectly in one space and when
they're perfectly aligned that means
that this is something technical because
normally reads are kind of you know
overlapping and you know parts mapping
here parts mapping there and there
different links etc so this is how we
know that this is amplification and we
want to get rid of that now afterwards
we have several options we can either
map on genome and then we would have to
detect the exons and map on junctions
and then construct the isoforms or we
can simplify the problem and focus just
on mapping on transcripts and
transcripts are already recorded in the
GTF file like we saw before and we're
just going to see whether the reads map
to those places or not and if not we'll
just leave them as non map reads so
we'll click as bowtie to T so you can
see that bowtie to T is again explained
here how exactly it maps and you can go
and read about the algorithm itself
right here so let's click on save and
the final thing that we need to do after
we map those reads is to quantify the
transcript abundances and so you can see
here that the previous algorithm created
the same file so this is the sequence
alignment that was produced there and
now we are going to quantify how many
reads fall onto each one of the known
sequences now quantification is not as
straightforward as you think
quantification of reads requires us to
have some expectation of general noise
so we expect the reads to be placed in
many different locations at
approximately the same rate but if there
is an abundance if there's some kind of
a natural variation there's actually in
the data we would expect that to have
some abundance above that level of noise
and that is what's called by expectation
maximization the other thing to remember
here is what values do we want to use
when we do this quantification do we
want to just have expected count or do
we want to use some normalization so
normalization that we have functional
here is fragments per kilo base per
million
or TPM which is transcript for a million
so we're gonna use fpkm click on save
New York also can create an exon table
but you don't have to and click on int
and now we have our first pipeline so
let's call it RNA seek first pipeline
click on save and now we can click on
run pipeline so now this pipeline is
running it's important to note right
here
1% started and also if I go under my
pipelines I have to see that it is green
and it is indeed processing so this is
how you create the pipeline for RNA seek
now there are several other options as
well as I mentioned we can map on genome
or even we can use alternative ways to
quantify so if you go under RNA to RNA C
2 you will notice that we added here
also a sailfish in HD sack which are
alternative methods of quantification